congratulations on the film thank you so
much
it covers a lot of ground
not just not just secular activism and
the opioid crisis but also Nan golden in
her personal history and and her work so
I think maybe as an entry point
what was your first point of contact for
making this film was it one of those
elements and then it broadened out sure
um so as an artist I've known Nan's work
and
um uh and you know how groundbreaking it
was from you know from the 80s I'd seen
the book I've seen the slideshow many
times and it's always been sort of
I think an inspiration like that what
she created both for narrative
storytelling for Cinema I mean so many
you know people talk cinematographers
talk about you know the sort of palette
that she uses and sort of drawing
inspiration from that so so of course I
knew her work
um we had met
um uh at some occasions it was a film
festival so we you know we knew each
other but we weren't we weren't friends
and um and then uh she started to she
created pain and she started doing these
actions and I had read about them so I
wasn't involved at the beginning
um Nan um when she created pain so she
as you see in the film she she wrote
this declaration an art form and then in
in March she did the action at the Met
and they um at that point she was she
was like we need to document everything
and make a film
and then um we had we had breakfast
together about a year or a year and a
half later she told me about the film
and I was thrilled because I had been
following it and I was so um
thrilled that an artist with her with
the kind of power she had was leveraging
her power in the way she was to hold the
secular family accountable and I just
thought it was an amazing story so I
just remember being really thrilled and
then I learned in the course of that
meeting she was looking for others to to
join the project including Howard
gertler who I'd known for since we'd
worked together on split screen with
John Pearson
um and she she asked about him as a
producer I said he'd be perfect he did
how to survive a plague which is also
incredible in terms of archival material
and showing you know activism like kind
of blueprint for activism and and how
direct action anyway and then I sort of
volunteered you know I kind of got in
and so
um that was the sort of entry point so
the entry point was knowing about this
the um
the activism that Nat was doing and it
was in in a lot of ways similar to
previous films I've made um you know an
individual portrait kind of confronting
power
activism but also a deeply personal film
and I like the fact that it's the
activism that started you connecting and
then he deepened in do you
some people say it's an it's a blend of
the personal and the political but I
want to put that to you isn't is
everything personal political and vice
versa do you make a distinction like
that
um you know I mean if you look at Nan's
artwork and you know you have you know
Maggie Smith who looked at her looked at
her films you know the woman who owns um
Tin Pan Alley you know I love that she
was the one that's like this is
profoundly political like and and so
deeply personal I mean I you know to
answer the question I mean I guess I
would say that you know there are very
few artists I think that go to the sort
of personal depths that man does
um and I do think it's profoundly
political
um and I I definitely felt that you know
anytime you start a project you know you
have to feel that you're the right
filmmaker for it and you have to be able
to contribute something and you know you
know I I was super nervous you know like
Nan's Force
um I was nervous like okay what can I
contribute and um and how to tell the
story that
um uh you know would would provide
insight and yeah and it was you know
it's I don't consider it a biography you
know I think that I consider it a
portrait and the kind of
you know my films often follow like a
contemporary through line like that some
sort of a sort of
um a drama that's unfolding in real time
you know that's a kind of filmmaking I
really love to do
um and then the personal and the sort of
um as we began working
other layers kind of revealed themselves
it seems to me in your interviews which
are very revealing with her that she
almost wanted to unburden herself of
some of this stuff that she wanted it
did you have to gain her trust or was
this a moment where she where she felt
like she wanted to talk about it I mean
you know I I don't want to speak for Nan
um we definitely yes I mean in terms of
there's a lot of trust that that that
was needed for the kind of intimacy that
you hear and you know when she talks
about her her work and that happened you
know we you know when I started the film
um we hadn't done any interviews and I
never really thought like oh I'm gonna
you know set up a camera and lights and
do a master interview or something that
just didn't seem that it was going to
you know lend itself to the kind of
intimacy but we did the first interview
and it was the interview that you hear
when she's talking about teenage years
and being sent to foster care and
meeting David Armstrong it was so
emotional for me to like you know what
she was sharing
um but it was also kind of like we went
to like a really deep emotional Place
really quickly and then we had to sort
of um you know just step back and say
well that's intense and we you know we
built
um some some ways that we could that she
and I could speak freely and then sort
of agree that later she could you know
have the opportunity to listen before
anyone else heard and to make sure that
there wasn't anything that was just too
personal
um so we you know that's kind of I think
how the trust was built and that was
done very much with
um participant and particularly Diane
Wireman I mean the film is dedicated to
her memory and she um this film wouldn't
exist without Diane um and she was very
supportive that we that the kind of that
we needed sort of safety nets around
because because of the emotional depth
something else that your film does that
I really love is that we see Nan's work
you create like mini installations
almost interspersed throughout your film
um which feels somewhat new for you I
wonder if there is an element to this
project that you felt you would grow as
a filmmaker yeah I appreciate that
question I mean yeah yeah I mean I do
feel that this you know the you know
every film is a you know there are
certain things you bring to it and then
there's certain things that like that
um the the people you work with allow
for and again you know this kind of
emotional depth and
um that and bravery of of Nan
allowed for I think an emotional you
know like you know something that really
goes someplace that I don't I haven't
and in my previous work and that is you
know this you know very much a
collaboration with Nan um and we you
know this structure I mean this is very
much like every piece of
um uh film it's a collaboration and you
know the editors who you know made this
possible I mean Joe beanie an
extraordinary editor um Amy foot and and
Nan was also involved sort of in the
later stages as we once we had a rough
cut we you know
she you know we want she watched and
then we went in and deepened a lot of
things that she felt like she wanted to
um go deeper into so cookie Mueller or
David Armstrong you're doing a service
for contemporary art and that whole
scene that old New York scene it's great
it's an education in that I'm struck by
how moved I was by the film and how
emotional it was for me it seems to me
like everyone has a story about the
opioid crisis that's how consequential
it is
um do you see the film as an opportunity
for discussion to happen about that
subject that's so often stigmatized yeah
foreign for sure I mean but both yeah
addiction opioid crisis
um
um you know sex work nahan talks about I
mean you know she talks about this you
know the the reasons
she's willing to talk about these very
personal
um things is to
um to destigmatize and not just to
destigmatize but you know pain would
often talk about like we need to shift
the shame from you know
towards the sacklers right that the
shame needs to be it's like misplaced
you know and Nan says that at the end of
the film that the wrong things are kept
secret you know and and I absolutely
agree and so I think what Payne was
doing is trying to like okay for the
people who need to be shamed are you
know the people who are profiting and
you know knowing that you know that
they're creating a product that's
killing people this is killed a
generation you know and it's been it's
been known like the you know the the the
way that this drug has been you know
promoted to doctors and um and abused it
was known from the early you know 2000s
I mean their journalists have been
reporting on this and then the idea that
it could continue
um and yeah so and you know know getting
back to another one of your questions in
terms of like how to approach this I
mean the anytime you make a documentary
it's also exists within sort of a
context and so the fact that there are
journalists like Patrick riding key for
Barry Meyer and other filmmakers I mean
Alex Gibney has made work and a lot of
other filmers filmmakers have made work
about the crisis which kind of then like
allows me to sort of it's it's there but
I'm assuming also that the audience is
bringing something and that that what I
felt was really unique was being able to
do a portrait of Nan and then also a
kind of Deep dive into you know activism
like what what what what is the you know
the Sparks or the that makes it
effective and
um and how can it be a bit of a
blueprint again you know Howard there's
how to survive a plague is an example of
you know you see how it happens not just
the results of a direct action right and
the change at the end is so profound I
wonder if you've what does nan think of
the film have you we did you show her
the cut before and were you worried
about that reaction well those are two
different questions I'm terrified uh
of course she's seen it I mean she's
seen it many times I mean we um we did
the interviews we did a rough cut and
then you know we we showed it with her I
mean you know the I think it's important
like this is really it's this is hard
this is hard for her
um
to to trust somebody else
um it's you know it's it concludes you
know her art her art has been about her
her life
um and and she's contributed you know at
every step of the way like and we felt
like I you know I felt the editing team
felt that you know the way that Nan
talks about her how she works with the
people she photographs that it is a
collaborative that people she lets
people tear something up if it's you
know like there is this kind of
collaborative that there was imperative
that this filmmaking also be
um in that Spirit you know which doesn't
mean I mean I'm still the director I had
the final you know Final Cut on the film
but it was collaborative and she brought
so much to you know to the film at every
stage
um so but I don't want to speak for her
so I think she's I hope she's proud
that's all I can say yeah maybe as a
general question for us to conclude
um
we look backward in your film to the
history we also look forward in terms of
how we can make a change as viewers and
participants what's more important to
you when we exit a film is taking it
with you is it like a tool something
that you can use I mean I always think
going forward I mean I you know there's
I I have you know some ambivalence about
even like storytelling like I don't want
the audience to leave with a sense of
closure and they've had some cathartic
experience that like exists within a
dark room and then they move out into
the world and it doesn't doesn't bleed
in right like I want the work to bleed
into people's lives and and not sort of
tie things up too neatly I felt that
very strong as a citizen for like and
and with this film like I I do you know
we I when I was working with Joe beanie
I was like you know like uh I want
people to think differently
um about a lot of things you know on the
most personal level and on a political
level in terms of how they move in the
world
this film's definitely making us think
differently let's thank our guests thank
you so much
thank you